I'm surprised that Boris Johnson managed
to come back with a deal slightly yes I
mean the thing to understand is that
since he was elected boris has had
people trying to undermine his
negotiating position at every turn you
know so I'm taking away this option take
away that option we're looking for
extension and despite that despite that
user would come back with it make them
reopen the negotiation whichever we said
was impossible and then change their
position sir and he's now they had to
write that letter
yeah requesting an extension delay I
mean do you think he had to write it
yeah I think I think he had no choice
that was the law but the irony of course
is that the Parliament can instruct you
to do something they can't instruct you
to change your mind and that's what he's
made paintin ly clear he hasn't changed
his mind he doesn't want an extension
yes the sender send the letter but
that's it but do you think that there's
a chance now that we might not leave the
EU at the end of October there's a
chance but I think it's a probability
well because he's got this deal and you
have to understand that the risk of no
deal from the European point of view is
if anything much worse than the risk for
us I mean there's a downside for us a
turbulence or come out if we we have no
deal but the risk for the cleland is
terrible the risk for the Netherlands
and Belgium the cross channel traffic is
terrible the risk for Germany is a
hundred thousand jobs so they want a
deal to happen so they want this they
want this deal to get through they've
struck the deal they want you to happen
so I think they'll do everything
possible to make it happen what can they
do it comes down to Parliament now and
if you say that no do what we say bad
for them then maybe they're just going
to go out another way there's not going
to answer until the end of the month
that leaves Parliament without with
having to make a sort of gamble if you
like you know if it rejects this deal if
it alters the what's called the wave the
withdrawal and implementation bill
they're the piece of law that makes it
happen if they if they don't accept that
or mess it around then they themselves
Parliament ending up taking the risk of
precipitate No Deal ironically
ironically yesterday's vote actually
makes No Deal slightly more likely not
less likely and it's interesting isn't
because you do admit that there is a
chance that we may not be
by the end of the month I just wonder
was it mistake for Boris Johnson to be
so firm in his promises that that would
happen I mean just to take one example
of the kind of thing that Prime Minister
has been saying recently we are getting
ready to come out on the 31st of October
come what may do-or-die that might not
happen now he's written the extension
know I know I said you say move go back
to the port the first question you asked
me well you know what this deal why did
this deal happen why did they reopen the
negotiation if you look back over three
months you can see every time Boris was
firm and determined about it they came
to the table to talk every time
Parliament undermined him they backed
off and started putting new conditions
on he's got to be determined he's got to
be clear about it he's got to be willing
to go to No Deal
nobody wants no dear I don't want No
Deal he doesn't want No Deal
but you've got to be willing to go that
route in order to get a good deal and
that's what he's done so do you think
the deal will get through Parliament
next week I think it will and there may
be attempts to to tack delays onto it
there may be attempts to to her to tie
his hands in the next stage remember
it's only halfway getting the next day
so you can't threaten No Deal well
that's when we get to saying okay but
have a general election but it'll get
through next week I think and the rant
and we spoke to a little earlier just
before yourself on the program was
saying that she would vote for the deal
she of course was strips at the concept
of weird if she does vote for the deal
do you think she should be allowed to
reap back into the party well I want I
want the the people who've left and
there's a 21 and hambar as she said it
chose to leave I want them to have a
route back but it's got to be on on
terms that we will deliver that the the
decision of the British people you know
but let me let me just pick up on what
amber said I mean it was a little bit
disingenuous she's a great mate of mine
so I can probably get away with this
yeah what happened in the course the
last nine months every softened
Parliament laid down terms and
conditions upon which the government
shall behave and the last terms and
conditions they laid down was you've got
to have a meaningful vote which allowed
Parliament to say yes or no to the deal
and if you don't you extend that's what
they say we get to yesterday and the
truth was that no matter whether
Parliament voted the deal or not we're
going to extend that was the effect of
the let win
legislation on Levin amendment and you
can't keep doing that you can't keep
doing that you've got to actually get
behind the Prime Minister and make the
deal work and you can't keep putting
conditions on coz all you're doing is
helping the European negotiators and I
don't really want to do that I mean
talking about getting behind the Prime
Minister I'm making the deal work if
there are conservative euro skeptics who
vote against the deal should they lose
the whip in the same way that the other
ones did when I was a whip in the most
unbelievably tough circumstances of the
Maastricht arrangers nobody lost to it
nobody nobody was deselected I stopped
them being D selected I'm not a great
believer in withdrawing whips there are
other dark arts that you could
potentially in persuasion for a start
it's actually saved me this is the best
deal you can possibly have I mean just
think about it two weeks ago people were
saying this was impossible that was the
words being used by European Union why
people are in your position by John
McDonnell but by people I can but I
don't know the ramber herself said well
people I can't
they also it's impossible now we've got
something let's make it work you say
that it is in your view a deal that
people should get behind but there are
some really genuine concerns about
what's in this deal particularly from
politicians in Northern Ireland and
earlier this week you know you said that
you would look personally at what Arlene
Foster the leader in the DEP had to say
about the deal and that it was very
important well we now know what the DP
of said and and this is what they've
said yeah when it comes to the deal they
have said these proposals are not in our
view beneficial to the economic
well-being of Northern Ireland and they
undermined the integrity of the Union I
mean how much cause for concern does
that last part give you you can bet that
I look very carefully in this and I look
at all the unionist people unions
politicians on this matter and I have
some sympathy with one element of it I
come back to in a second but I think
that's wrong I think it's wrong for a
couple of reasons a threat to the Union
know the details show you actually it's
not and the best test of that is look at
what David Trimble said David Trimble
put his life literally his life on the
line for the Good Friday Agreement he
was one of the authors of it and he says
this is not a threat the Union
in terms of economics what does it do
firstly it says you can take anything
any product from North Island sell it
into the UK no checks at all going the
other way if it's Britain the rest of
Britain to Northern Ireland then and to
sell in Northern Ireland no checks at
all either
it's only when we're selling things
Norlin which may go south or may be a
part of something going south and so
from that point of view it's the
lightest possible touch and in exchange
for that they are going to be able to
benefit from every new trade deal we do
that's that that's about you so I know I
looked at very carefully I've invested a
lot of my life in Northern Irish issues
one way and another so I care deeply
about this but I think they're wrong and
I thought about it very hard I don't
know I deliberately didn't commit myself
beginning the week because I wanted to
see the detail and I think they're not
right I mean you know the the bit where
I think they've got a point is that
we've changed the mechanisms decision
what Boris has managed to do is get the
European Union to accept that north
bound itself will make decisions every
few years every four years they make a
decision whether this is working for
them or not
but the decision is on the basis of it a
majority not every community agree
that's the one thing thank you I just
wonder if you are under a complicated I
know if the differences say because we
know that Northern Ireland's will have
to follow certain rules the rest the
United Kingdom will not on v80 on food
standards there will be Czechs in the
Irish and in the Irish Sea between
Northern Ireland and the rest of the
United Kingdom and I appreciate that
people can choose you know certain
politicians and Northern Ireland very
important politicians like mr. Trimble
but there are others who have deeply
held concerns about what this means for
the future of the Union yeah no doubt
that there are those legitimate concerns
in that but just look back into why I
had the the misfortunes of being Europe
Minister during the mad cow disease
crisis and a long time ago but in the
middle of that one
Irish policy Northern Irish politician
said we want British Catholic before it
comes into Northern Ireland
know who that was that was Ian Paisley
senior the greatest unionist of all time
in many ways and you know that's because
in practical terms he saw this was good
for his constituents good for known are
to protect them from a problem and
that's what this is and they'll have
every four years they'll have a chance
to say yes or no this is working for us
or not working for us and it may sound
not very often but actually these things
don't change very fast you know the
regulations on on chemicals or
regulations on car manufacture don't
change every every few months they
change every five or ten years and
that's that they'll have a chance to
actually exercise their judgment on that
which actually is one of the brilliant
things that Boris pulled off because
that wasn't even on the table in
previous negotiations and well we've got
you we introduced you saying you you
were the original breaks that's yeah
what mistakes do you think the UK is
made in these negotiations well you need
a little my resignation letter really
but the but as we started off accepting
the sequencing now very techy thing but
basically we talked about the European
Union's issues before we got around to
talking about ours we should have been
able to trade one off against the other
we gave away too much in terms of full
alignment so-called full alignment it's
all quite techie stuff I'm afraid we
conceded too much at every turn we were
not tough enough bluntly we're simply
not tough enough and I think and this
issue of No Deal
it's quite important it European Union
did not believe Theresa May meant it
when she said no deal is better than a
bad deal so that's what that all of that
telegraphed that we were going to be
easy to roll over and that's what they
tried to do Boris stop that don't worry
about taking details we love a bit of
detail how about you personally
are there any mistakes that you made and
undoubtedly vast numbers come on then
give us but it's actually for historians
rather me to judge that I should I maybe
I should have threatened to read I never
I don't believe in threatens to resign
but maybe I should have done at the
other point the when when we actually
made that concession on Northern Ireland
but you know that was interesting on the
day it's quite funny in front with
hindsight we came back to have the
Commons I thought this this concession
we may
we'll get terrible handling in the House
of Commons everybody thought it was
wonderful the opposition thought it was
wonderful
the ERG thought it was wonderful Jacob
Riis Marx was one when I sit I think
maybe I've made a mistake in thinking it
was wrong maybe Therese was right and I
was wrong actually it turned out of
course I did turn it be right in the
long run but not sure if that really
counts as a mistake I know no mistake I
just as an observation that's what